[Music]
good people of Iran want change and
other than the vast military power of
the United States that Iran's people are
what their leaders fear the most
oppressive regimes cannot endure forever
and the day will come when the people
will face a choice will they continue
down the path of poverty bloodshed and
terror or will the Iranian people return
to the nation's proud roots as a center
of civilization culture and wealth where
their people can be happy and prosperous
once again that was the president that
was back in September at the United
Nations predicting the unrest that is
now spreading in Iran tonight earlier
today the president tweeted such respect
for the people of Iran as they try to
take back their corrupt government now
you will see great support from the
United States at the appropriate time
here with the reaction former US
ambassador to the UN Fox News
contributor John Bolton and National
Iranian Congress Senate chairman
president of the Iranian freedom
Institute Amir [ __ ] lava is with us good
to see you and just as we don't have the
time like I did on radio today to get
into all your background your student
pushing for freedom and liberty you were
in prison in Iran for nearly six years
every bone in your body was broken you
were tortured tell everybody what
happened first of all thank you for
having me here and this is a great
opportunity to send a message of
millions of young people in Iran who are
chanting death to dictator and therefore
the Ayatollah him dead - how many dead -
Ayatollah and no aloha questioned at all
that means these are the right keys that
the Americans and the international
community should have focused on them
and should help them because these are
the people who can change the entire
Middle East and interval if we can
change the regime of Iran then bring up
the democratic and free that would mean
radical Islamic mullahs
chant death to America death to Israel
will not be married to nuclear weapons
that they seek so desperately exactly
and if you realize the first question
you asked about me I don't want to talk
about myself honestly the people can go
and google my name and then they can
well I think it's what you were beaten
you were exactly every bone in your body
nearly richer for more than five years
and three months and eight months of
solitary confinement and a lot of bones
in my body have been broken but right
now my classmates my friends they are in
street they are chanting they want the
better let me ask you and you have
helped organize what's happening today
you are in touch with them every day how
do you win a revolution without weapons
when you have the Kurds the the
Revolutionary Guard and the other
military and first of all let me thank
you for mentioning that the regime is
calling I won just they say the exact
quote they are calling these protests as
spontaneous reaction to economic
hardships and this is coming from the
regime and that's very interesting
because some media is here they are
exactly echoing this message no this is
not correct these kids in Iran they plan
for that we plan for that because this
is a revolution will this be successful
volution wait let me go to ambassador
balton ambassador you have been an
advocate I think we made such a big
mistake and I'm sure mayor agrees with
me back in 2009 I don't know many many
revolutions that winged win with
slingshots and baseball bats if people
are an armed ambassador my fear is we
will wake up to a massacre of a lot of
these young students that is a fear that
I believe is quite legitimate sadly no I
think that's right and I think you know
the United States has an obligation here
the president has been correct in his
tweets about support for the opposition
but we have in our past called out
opposition's into the streets and
Hungary and Eastern Europe in the 1950s
in Iraq after the first Persian Gulf War
and then stood by while they were
slaughtered and I don't
should we do well I think we've got to
go to the various aspects of the
Opposition this is a very complex
phenomenon that's going on and see what
we can do to help them I think in the
immediate near-term they need
Communications help inside Iran because
the government has been effective and
shutting down or slowing down the
Internet I think they need finances so
that they can communicate better inside
Iran and ultimately they may need
assistance more than that now the
opposition here in the United States
which is pretty fearsome says oh my
goodness that would taint what's going
on in Iran you know honestly the people
who know best what they need are the
opposition figures inside Iran if
they're content to take American and
other outside support I think we should
provide it to them here what would you
like this president to do and how how is
this going to be successful do you
believe the military will turn on
Khamenei and you know my father was a
Air Force Army officer I'm coming from
the military family but traditional
military in Iran we know not the card
forces not a revolutionary revolution
there their exterior fraction is called
coats force this is two different
military force and the traditional army
they have been with the people from the
day you believe they are today they are
today we have seen several thought about
the Revolutionary Guard the
Revolutionary Guard did a body of
Revolutionary Guard right now they are
turning their face and their commanders
but the commanders we cannot just
content them but as you asked the
Ambassador John Bolton I want to use
this opportunity to say thank you to
ambassador Bolton because he was right
all the time when it comes to Iran he
was on the right side of history Thank
You ambassador and about what the United
State can do and specifically okay
specifically president Trump right now
the people in Iran they are hungry they
love president Trump they will love him
more if he can do something to make sure
we will have internet coverage all over
Iran satellite internet they get the
story you get the videos out get the
images
and then how thing is this how many this
is huge we are talking about millions of
millions of people they need it they can
be the army of the world to make world
free from this small group of fanatic
mothers who are in power in Iran I've
got a run
wish you all in your quest for freedom
ambassador always appreciate you being
on thank you sir